[Music]
great to have you back on the show
welcome to the studio IRA fondly recall
last time doing this cramped in a tiny
hotel room down in like Marina del Rey
you know the airport so I appreciate you
coming up here to do it again
well thanks for having us yeah a lot
nicer yeah it's a little bit more
comfortable hopefully and super excited
about your book congratulations
fantastic it's a great read I found it
to be super enlightening and instructive
and helpful and look forward to
deconstructing it with you guys here
today let's do it yeah man so first of
all it feels like you just wrote a book
five minutes ago and now you have
another book coming out so what is that
about before we even get into what the
book is like good yeah so the the short
answer is that we really like to write
and we wear these ideas the the longer
answer is the the first book that we
wrote peak performance had a pretty long
runway from when we submitted the
manuscript to when it was published and
we had planned to spend this time
together to refine the manuscript and it
turned out that that manuscript didn't
need as much refining as we thought so
we had weeks on her hands in person and
Steve lives in Houston I'm in Northern
California
and he just started writing another book
so this book was more or less done
before peak performance oh wow that's
crazy that's amazing so your process in
terms of writing I mean how much time do
you actually spend in person because you
have lives on separate coasts easily
yeah not a lot actually not a lot so we
probably for this book probably only
spent maybe three long weekends together
there's something like that right three
or three long weekends in a week though
when we really come up with the idea and
that's where it like our process that's
where the kind of magic happens is like
the idea generation phase that's where
we need to be together where we're just
throwing ideas back and forth
like kind of coming up with the outline
of like hey what does this look like
once it comes to the writing process
like we just have this refined you know
process where you know Brad takes a
little bit I take a little bit we share
it back and forth and right it's just
super in in sync so do you have another
book that you've basically completed
there will be coming out nine months
from now our agent thank you Michael
accepted right I'm gonna plead the fifth
right and we should say because there's
a lot of new listeners since the last
time you guys were on Steve elite track
and field running coach lives in Houston
Brad lives in Oakland writer journalist
with a background in consulting and a
whole story that we went into in detail
the last time you guys were here but it
is a yin and a yang thing like Steve
brings this kind of firsthand athlete
coach science perspective and Brad
brings kind of the journalistic approach
to these these ideas that you're
exploring and it seems like a nice
synergistic way to kind of broach these
topics yeah it's it's worked out well I
mean it's worked out well if first and
foremost we judge by the fact that this
has been super fun and we get I hate to
do stuff that we love and we like
working together so yeah it's cool
fortunate all right so passion the
passion the passion paradox right I
think this is very much of the moment
we're in a culture where we talk a lot
about chasing our passion finding our
bliss living our bliss living our most
authentic selves our best selves and
there's a lot of terminology that gets
thrown in there from motivation to
inspiration to obsession and passion of
course is sort of a catchphrase for all
of that but I'm not sure we really
understand our terminology so maybe the
best place to begin this is to define
all of our terms yes what is passion
mean essentially is what I'm asking like
how do you think about passion it
depends
so that that was more or less the
starting point for this book was asking
that question what does it mean to be
passionate and the word passion itself
comes from the Latin root Paseo and the
definition of Paseo is to suffer so
passion first and foremost meant
suffering the word was created in a
religious connotation with the
crucification of Jesus and it was the
suffering of Christ on the cross paseo
The Passion of the Christ exactly and
then over time the word slowly morphed
to this broader sense of desire but it
was still tied up in suffering for about
the first fourteen hundred years of its
usage only more recently was passion
something that one would want to strive
for where that would be linked to a good
life it's a weird twist like what what
caused that change in the way that we
perceived that word do we know or yeah
I'm not sure exactly we know we actually
talked to a couple experts who her
experts at etymology and word
linguistics and it seemed like actually
around like Shakespeare it starts to
begin this change cuz he used it in the
context of like love which was the first
kind of what I'd call positive somewhat
usage of it but even there it had this
like negative connotation towards that
and it wasn't until like the turn of the
20th century where you start seeing it
in in the modern usage of it oh yeah
like hey you need to find your passion
or passion is something that is good
that is something that we should search
for and it really wasn't until you know
Presley 1960s 1970s where we see this
whole kind of cultural change of like
find your passion yeah it's so
interesting but I think there's
something to that that Shakespearean
perspective because it may it seems to
make sense that that that kind of pain
element can be built into this idea of
what it means to feel strongly right
because because pain and suffering
are really not a very distant cousin to
these strong emotions around love and
how we think about passion today right
there they're just a shred they're just
a little tweak to one side yeah they are
they're exactly that they're close
cousins maybe even brother and sister
two sides of the same coin that is
really interesting too in the the
research of the book learning not just
about how the word is used in how we
perceive people following their passion
or people suffering but also the
neurology of someone that is very
passionate versus somebody that is an
addict or suffering from mental illness
or some dysfunction what's happening in
the brain is very similar if not the
same well I'm I have personal interest
in that so let's explore that like what
is the difference because again those
are two things that are very close to
each other like and I've asked myself
this question like am I just passionate
about doing this or do I have an
unhealthy sort of obsessive relationship
with this pursuit and I'm telling myself
that I'm passionate about it and
sometimes it's not clear yeah I mean and
and that's where actually the origins of
this whole thing started or the whole
our exploration of it as we've seen in
ourselves some of these like obsessive
tendencies I mean we were writing a book
before our first book came out yeah
right we have these obsessive tendencies
and we were sitting there just talking
about like hey is this a good thing or
is this a bad thing or is this something
we should pull back on or push forward
on and that's kind of where it we had
this debate of like hey wait a minute is
passion good bad what is it how does
obsession tie into it and those were at
the root of of what we were exploring
and if you look at you know some of the
biology of it right we looked at the
biology of addiction and of desire and
hormonal E and then neurologically so
both on a hormone level and on a brain
level like they're very very closely
related
uh-huh it's it's almost impossible to
sit there and be like oh no this
person's like their brain shows there
they're actually in love versus addicted
right
the the only thing that I would add to
that and maybe this gets back to your
original question is I would say that
passion isn't good or bad it just is
mm-hmm and it can very much be both of
those things can be both of those things
for the same person over the course of
their life sometimes it can be both of
those things on the same day both of
those things being what what are the
good or good or bad a blessing I mean we
can we can we can place a value judgment
on it I mean it just is right so whether
it's bad or good maybe we don't know in
the immediate moment and we only know in
retrospect years later but I think a
good litmus test is the impact that it's
having on other areas of your life like
if it's setting in motion a domino
effect of damage and you know like like
scorched earth relationships and you
know failing to live up to other
responsibilities then we could probably
qualify it as obsessive or addictive and
thus negative as opposed to a
sustainable passion you know flame
that's burning in a healthy way which is
kind of what you know you discuss in the
later chapters of the book totally and I
think that you you just nailed the
distinction right so the definition or a
working definition of addiction at least
one that I use is the relentless pursuit
of something despite negative
consequences you could say that passion
is the relentless pursuit of something
with positive consequences yeah or or at
least with neutral consequences yeah or
despite the the pursuing it despite the
lack of like public acknowledge like you
would do it anyway whether you're making
money at it or whether you're being sort
of lauded for it if you're passionate
enough about it it should propel you
nonetheless exactly 100% and if you look
at like some of the research that's been
done around this they actually like
distinguish it between what we call a
harmonious passion an obsessive passion
and how you distinguish that is exactly
that right it's something that you're
doing because you enjoy the activity
that you would do regardless or is it
something that's being driven by some
like external pursuit or some sort of
fear that you wouldn't you wouldn't
actually
you that activity if it was just up to
you right so all you have to do for the
sort of most extreme example of the
negative and what you just described
just look to any villain and a Marvel
movie yeah totally you know the the the
ultimate manifestation of obsessive
passion gone awry right and perhaps that
started with a laudable idea but it
became perverted and just the continuous
doubling down on it until it becomes you
know this dark yeah and I force of
nature it's it's when you say it that
extreme it's a little bit more
black-and-white you know what fascinates
us is that I think that a lot of people
start out with harmonious passion they
love the thing itself but then they
start to see some good results mhm and
our human species evolved to want to see
good results social standing rewards
like that's a big part of evolution so
it's the slippery slope to starting off
doing an activity because you love it
but then without perhaps even noticing
doing the activity not because you love
the thing but you love the external
validation and the recognition that the
thing brings you and that can become
dangerous now the flip side is also true
that very few people just do the thing
because they love the thing like we're
not robots it feels good to be
recognized but at what point are you
chasing the recognition more than the
activity itself and that's where lots of
people both in regular life as well as
world-class performers really struggle
well also with success success begets
obligation right because then what
you're doing becomes institutionalized
so all you have to do is look at you
know whether it's Tiger Woods or Michael
Phelps like any super successful athlete
it starts with passion as a kid in a
healthy way doing this thing that you
love and then the success turns this
into you know essentially an industry in
which there's a lot of people relying
upon the perpetuation of that success
the love for the thing itself begins to
wane and it becomes about money and
career and legacy and then you know then
the crisis happens that either breaks
person or helps to rebuild them and
allows them to come back stronger
totally right I mean that's kind of like
you see this beginning that archetype
getting played out and play it out and
play it out and you know in my personal
experience with this podcast like this
began is like a tiny little thing and
now it's like a thing right it's not
like the biggest thing in the world but
like to think there's people that help
me and they're here and you got to be
here there's lights we're filming this
like this is not how it started and you
don't think we feel that way on the
other side of the mic right yeah what
are two young guys that's not a book
because we like writing and suddenly
people are buying our book and you want
to have us and talk to you does that
mean and what does it mean we know what
we're doing right now you have an agent
and your agent says well what's the next
book you know and then and then it's the
the nature of the thing itself
inevitably changes right and what does
that say about passion or what passion
means or the quality of passion that is
underlying everything that you're doing
and why you're doing it yeah exactly and
I think the other thing that it's really
important or interesting is it's also
your relationship to that activity like
your identity being tied to it as you
have success mm-hmm like we found you
know talking to a bunch of different
peoples it's that moment where you go
from oh I really enjoy this I'm really
passionate then it almost transforms to
like this is who I am
you know I'm Steve the runner because I
was good at running right or you know
you're rich roll the podcast guy because
this has blown up and it's people know
you by that but then you yourself
started identifying yourself only in
this regard yeah and I think what we
found is that that kind of spirals this
passion thing towards the negative
almost obsessive connotation because
then it becomes like oh if you know Brad
and I are known as writers and we write
this poor book now it's just not like oh
we feel that writing we're not good at
writing it's no Brad and I failed right
right so it's like that you are failure
yes exactly
yeah well once you become associated
with a certain thing and you're
successful in that regard
then your identity becomes calcified
around it and then you feel this
pressure to live up to it so if this
book is super successful maybe you have
the ability to say well I'm never gonna
write another book again I don't feel
like it or whatever but then you would
inevitably find yourself butting up
against that sense of disor tustin's
with this identity that you work so hard
to create right
it's a weird thing I think so I I'd like
to think that if it got to that point
and the reason that it's like nope never
writing another book is cuz didn't want
to write I'd like to think I'd have the
guts we'd have the guts to do it
uh-huh I think that we still like to
write but that other stuff is still
there so in the book there's this
there's the section on the harmonious
and obsessive passion and how the two
can take different forms at different
times of someone's life and personally I
just shoot for 51 percent of my passion
to be harmonious and as long as the
majorities coming from I like the act
itself then I'm fine getting excited by
other things cuz when I was researching
this book in writing it with Steve I got
into this phase where I started like
just getting stuck in my head and like
judging myself am I just doing this
because I want to sell books am I just
doing this because I want people to take
me seriously or do I actually like
writing and Steve's been real helpful at
this just the two can coexist so long is
the fuel for the activity is the
predominant one you should be in a
pretty healthy relationship with the
thing mmhmm yeah that's so how do you
gauge that fifty one percent like how do
you know that you're like for me I you
have to be really honest with yourself
but then sometimes I don't even trust my
own barometer like I may say well I'm
doing this because I love it but then
like what part of my psyche and my
shrouding and not really being
completely open with yeah you're and I'm
saying yeah I'm sorry and I think that's
why you know Brad mentioned the
conversations we have but we talk about
this all the time uh-huh and I think
that's part of the
outlet is talking to somebody from the
outside who knows you really well but
can see those like changes in your
behaviors and changes of like your
attitude towards doing things right and
like that's where it's been really
helpful and not only are our writing
relationship but our friendship a
friendship of like calling calling each
other is the important right well I
think this central sort of the central
question that you're asking in this book
and and I would imagine was a motivating
factor and bringing expression of these
ideas is we're in this cultural moment
right now as I kind of alluded to at the
beginning where we're encouraged to
there's a there's a kind of war of ideas
where on the one hand it's like follow
your passion you know you only live once
you know life is short you're a
millennial go travel the world who cares
and then the responsible voice on the
other shoulder saying passion is
overrated like we're in a we're in a
culture of hot takes right so what's the
hot take well like the hot take now is
to say like passions [ __ ] right
you know don't listen to your passion
maybe you shouldn't follow your passion
you should follow through on the thing
that you're good at or the thing that
could perhaps provide you with you know
a solid career path for the next 20 or
30 years and reconciling these two ideas
kind of bashing up up against each other
seems to be the tension or the friction
that's kind of birth the ideas that come
through on the book yeah 100%
and and that's that's the title right
the passion paradox people want black or
white mm-hmm they don't like it depends
it depends is not such a great answer
but with passion like then I think Steve
thinks the answer really is it depends
and that's why we wrote the book is to
figure out well it depends on what like
what is a good passion what is a bad
passion you can absolutely be reckless
to pursue something that you have no
business pursuing financially for your
relationships but it can also be
reckless to stay in the same old rut
that you've been in in the book we try
to tease out well well how do you work
with these questions in a way that feels
right for you and that also is setting
you up to have a healthy relationship
with the thing yeah
in other words this subtitle for this
book could be like how to follow your
passion in a very respectful responsible
way that your parents would approve of
I'm kidding you know I thought it is
like responsible being being a
responsible passionate person yeah I
mean stuff comes out so so so one one
clear example of I guess maybe is like
responsible passionate person so there's
this notion that if you're passionate
about something you should drop what
you're doing and like pursue like your
heart's desire there have been books
written about this like you should
follow your must mmm-hmm and what the
research shows is actually the complete
opposite that the best way to cultivate
a passion is to do so very incrementally
and gradually over time
so if one's passion was becoming a
professional podcaster the the answer is
not to quit your job and start
podcasting it's to start podcasting as a
hobby I can assure you in you grad and
you gradually work up to a spot where
then maybe you gain the confidence based
on evidence that you can go all-in and
the reason that this works is because
you can take more risks when you have
the safe thing supporting you which is a
very different narrative I mean I didn't
hear that narrative growing up I heard
either take the safe path or if you take
the safe path you're gonna be bored all
your life follow your passion you know
don't worry about it have no regrets and
those two things don't have to be in
opposition to each other yeah yeah it
doesn't have to be a binary thing go
ahead yeah and I think one other thing
one other nuance thing that Brad pointed
out there is a lot of times we hear find
your passion and that implies that there
is something out there that you're going
to be passionate about but I think what
we found and what we're trying to get
out is it's not about finding it it's
about cultivating it right it's not that
hey the moment I start writing like I'm
gonna be deeply in love with writing you
know if you asked me 10 years ago if I
was gonna write a book like I've been
like nope no way like I hate writing
don't want to do it in school anything
like that
but now I love it enjoy it and part of
that was like a process of like writing
blogs and articles and like coming to
enjoy that
and what the research clearly shows is
it's not like a soulmate where there's
one passion out there that you can find
is that you can cultivate this in
different things that you're interested
in so what we really suggest is almost
become like serial gobblers and like
look at different things you're
interested on and try them out and if
they have that fuel to become a passion
like you'll be you'll become aware of it
and you'll cultivate I like that I think
that's really important too because it's
one thing to say to have this discussion
should you follow your passion or not
passion being something that didn't even
exist in the lexicon a couple hundred
years ago right but I think the more
common thing is that people don't even
know what their passion is it's like oh
how convenient you have a passion you're
trying to figure out whether you should
pursue it like I don't even know you're
like I've just been doing my job and
what you know like I I'm so disconnected
that I don't even know what I would do
if I could do it and that I think goes
to the heart of what ails so many people
and so the idea that like relieving the
pressure valve like don't feel bad if
you don't have a passion right actually
most people don't try stuff that you
think is cool and like don't judge
yourself and I gotta give credit to
Steve Steve is so good about this
passion is such a charged word that like
you said you feel bad I don't have a
passion but just Falls you have this
idea that people are just jumping out of
bed in the morning like write it up and
just can't wait to get to work or
whatever but it's more about interest
like the the the seed for passion is
interest and everyone has interests and
it's about following your interests and
I can almost assure you that if you have
an interest in your first thought is how
can I monetize this you probably will
not monetize it but if your first
thought is I really love doing this
thing I'm gonna spend more time doing it
and I'm gonna invest in my own growth
doing this this thing whether it's
writing running owning a business in a
relationship you name it then over time
it will become very clear if that's
something that makes sense for you to
monetize and give more of your time to
yeah I mean what I always say is is
think about the things that you enjoyed
most as a young person that kind of fell
by the wayside as you
older and some of those are silly but
some of those are very primal and may
still be relevant and it's not about
monetization or quitting your job or you
know monopolizing your time but if you
can recapture one of those interests and
breathe a little life into it as an
adult and just fan that flame and do it
simply because you enjoy doing it that's
the win in and of itself and should that
lead you on a you know path that tweaks
your trajectory going forward
professionally then that's gravy but
it's not necessarily about that yeah
it's it's you know that's a two-phase
process so there's that which is doing
it not not thinking about success and
that's your most likely like I said to
have success success monetization that
should all be a byproduct that shouldn't
be the end goal so that's the first part
of the book is outlining well how do you
do that what's the process for
cultivating your passion how do you know
when to pull back how do you know when
to push forward then the second part is
oh wow like I've got some success then
it's everyone just says we'll follow
your passion well then it's that
slippery slope to craving and need more
success in need more followers and more
money and more recognition so then once
you have this success well then how do
you nurture and nourish your passion so
it stays harmonious so like the way the
society looks at this is asked backwards
right it's find your passion doesn't
work like that and then it's like oh and
you have passion just like follow it
with reckless abandon your crushing like
nope that's a slippery slope to craving
in suffering and anxiety and depression
and burnout and all sorts of bad things
right and that's something you
experienced in your personal life right
yeah you know it's it's I don't know how
much of it would necessarily be related
to the passion itself but I step back
for a second so I'm in recovery for
obsessive-compulsive disorder which is
really misunderstood thing I always
thought growing up obsessive compulsive
disorder was like someone that needed to
be super clean or super organized to
just wash in your hand right enslave
who's spent time at my family's house
and with me I can tell you like neither
super clean nor super organized
but obsessive-compulsive disorder is
actually characterized by any kind of
recurring intrusive thought that is
accompanied by a devastating feeling and
these thoughts can hit you 10,000 times
a day just non-stop and then the
compulsion is anything to make that
thought go away
so in the hand-washing example someone
might constantly be thinking that
they're dirty they're gonna get sick and
how do you make that go away you wash
your hands and then the thought comes
back and you wash your hands again
that's only one type of OCD the the type
that I suffered from and occasionally
still do is related to us self-harm so I
have these awful thoughts that I should
harm myself and it's one thing to have a
crazy thought but they're accompanied by
urges and feelings to really do it me
and my compulsion was then reassuring
myself so in my mind trying to
problem-solve it oh I would never do
that I have no reason to be feeling this
way I should be happy but the circuits
in the brain just go totally haywire and
you get caught in this vicious cycle and
that hit me about two months after peak
performance came out yeah I don't think
that it had any relation to the fact
that the book was successful I do think
that I'm a very dopamine driven person
I'm very excitable good conversation
excites me doing well excites me writing
excited like exists in excitement and
excitement is fueled by this
neurochemical dopamine and a lot of
research on OCD shows that OCD is just
like the dopamine circuits going totally
haywire so my psychiatrist can't say
like I can't say no one will really know
maybe I was predisposed and this would
have happened regardless but a story
that I tell myself is that when that
book came out there was so much dopamine
going on because I was just excited I
was having conversations like this
things were great that eventually the
brain just short-circuited it and it was
like from that to just the worst
experience in my life
mmm yeah you described it as it's called
pure oh yeah pure Oh what does that mean
so pure Oh is a way that clinicians and
patients people that suffer can
categorize it from other OCD so the pure
o stands for pure obsession
so I didn't have any visible compulsions
I see it wasn't like I was walking my
hands my compulsion was again trying to
problem-solve or reassure myself and
there's nothing like a book release to
set in motion you know a cascade of
dopamine activating activities like
refreshing your Amazon ranking and all
that kind of craziness that goes along
with it so it's not a surprise that that
was sort of yeah the one thing I will
say is in case there are listeners that
are either confused or maybe suffering
themselves is that I always thought that
OCD or anxiety was just like what I used
to experience as anxiety it like a
hundred degrees uh-huh it's a totally
different animal like there was no
slippery slope from like excitement of
the book I can't stop thinking - OCD it
was like I mean it's terrifying it felt
like my brain was just completely taken
over there was a week when I thought
maybe I developed schizophrenia I mean
it was literally losing your minds and
having just enough insight to know that
you lost her mind [ __ ] terrifying so
thankful that I have health insurance
and then I was able to get help that I
have a supportive family and now I'm
here having this conversation about it
like it's this crazy thing but when I
was in it I didn't know was gonna happen
it was really scary yeah the irony of
being the guy who who co-wrote the the
peak performance book you know about
like how you mentally approach yeah
performing at your best to then have
this you know succumb to this kind of
episode but then I don't know how much
time passed after the acute phase of it
but you decide to share this and you
write about this for outside yeah so
that happened about August that came out
in March I think so about eight months
after the honest answer after uh-huh and
and what precipitated that was actually
a singular event I was in Virginia with
my brother on what was supposed to be a
fun vacation to run the the Virginia
like the Charlottesville half marathon
or not Charlottesville excuse me the
richmond half marathon and I was just
having a miserable time of with OCD that
weekend
supposed to be there with my brother
having a good time and like all I could
think about was driving the car off the
road and it just [ __ ] sucks and I
remember being at a coffee shop and
pulling up my email and I had like four
emails from 20 to 30 year old guys that
are in the spirit of you're only 31
you wrote this kick-ass book you've got
it all figured out how do you do it and
I'm sitting there with that stuff going
on in my mind in it it just broke me and
the cognitive dissonance and the
distress that that caused was almost as
bad as the OCD itself and at that moment
I'm like I just can't live like this so
I either need to stop writing because
I'm a total imposter I'm a fraud or I
need to come out and own this and the
things that I write about are pretty
personal always so there was no like
there was no if ands or buts and and for
a while I'm like me I just won't write
like maybe this isn't for me
and again thank goodness the supportive
therapist is like no like that's the
worst thing you could do that's giving
in to the OCD like [ __ ] own it um so
yeah I decided to write about it you
know not it had the byproduct of helping
a lot of people but if I'm being totally
honest did I want to help other people
sure but when I wrote that it was really
more for myself to just eliminate that
total feeling of being a fraud yeah the
dissonance and the catharsis with that
but it had to be hard to hit publish on
that but I would imagine that's got to
be of everything you've written I mean
that seemed to really connect with
people in a in a profound and also a
viral way yeah and you know that's like
the unintended by-product thing that
story blew up and people were offering
me book deals about that issue and I'm
like whoa like let's all pause like I'm
no person to be an expert I just shared
my experience I think it goes to show
that there are a lot of people
especially in the industry that I'm in
that Steve's in that yeren this like
self-help genre that just act like they
have all their stuff together few people
probably do if anyone I mean that's why
we connected right you've been so
authentic and and I'll say this because
it's really true
one of my core values is authenticity
and I was deciding whether or not to
write the story I know I've shared this
with you in an email and I said what
would rich do rich would probably do it
and that's kind of what you did in your
own way and then I did it and nothing
really changed like I shared it didn't
make the OCD go away Steve super helpful
there as a friend
Steve's been through some hard things in
his life he warned me that when the
story gets published you're gonna feel
like you've like conquered it you
declared victory like don't get trapped
by that like it doesn't make the
underlying thing go away and I felt good
for a day and then the next day like you
suck like you shouldn't have written
this like right life's awful which was
good so I kind of knew it was coming and
I'm like okay like this thing doesn't
just go away mm-hmm and it took like a
year of going to therapy once a week for
the thing to go away but serratus gone
there is something about owning it and
then sharing it publicly that that that
is a pressure-release right I don't do
those emails anymore yeah now it's like
you you you seem to have all your stuff
together and yet it also seems like you
completely fall apart so much better
well yeah that that whole projection of
like how can I be like you you're living
this idealized life is you know it's
it's weird when you're on the receiving
end of that I can't stand the word
self-help I struggle with the word
authenticity because it's been so
co-opted etc but these are all important
ideas right like I don't consider myself
a self-help person really like I'm just
trying to have interesting conversations
with people I'm as flawed and as human
as anybody and it's and as frightening
as it as it may be sharing our frailties
and our and our flaws I think is what
connects us more deeply with our fellow
humans in this shared experiment that
we're having yeah I think it's
incredibly important just to like get
the message out there that like no one
has it figured out yeah you know we're
all kind of mud I got news for ya no one
does you know it doesn't matter how much
of an expert you know I've you know
worked with some world-class athletes
who are just you know going into
meet our just jittery and anxious messes
right because they don't have it figured
out either where everyone's looking at
them like oh they're the ones they have
the answer
exactly and you you have a very I mean
we talked about this last time but it's
in the new book and I think it is
relevant to what we're talking about
today have had your own you know journey
with all of this as somebody who came
out of the gate you know as this
incredible runner almost broke four
minutes for the mile ran 401 and then
this becomes the quote-unquote like
identity that like follows you around
for a very long period of time to the
point where you just want to get as far
away from it as possible so talk a
little bit about like how that evolution
has brought you to this yeah I mean it's
kind of the heart of this book I hate
it's it's that fact that I loved running
absolutely we loved I mean I would do it
even if I didn't race anything like that
but then you get success right and then
you get known for this and then you know
at 18 I'm running on you know a
professional meet on NBC live and like
cameras on me and all this stuff and
then your identity becomes wrapped
around it right where it for for a while
I struggled and still struggle on you
know am i Steve the failed runner
because I never went under four never
met my expectations
but you're the only one who attaches
that word to that right exactly and one
else is like that dude ran 401 or
exactly but it in your head at that
moment like youth you blow it up into
this big thing of people must see me
this way
and you know for a long time like I'd
show up for you know a weekend 5k local
race and I would hate it if someone
recognized me out there because I'd be
like well I'm just gonna go run you know
15 16 minutes or something not up to
like my par of right what I thought was
good enough now with this
being out there and doing things and
like for years I didn't race because of
that for years like kind of regretted or
it didn't have a good relationship with
running which is something that again I
grew up loving and was a passion and all
that stuff so how did you get to the
other side of it you know I I think I
think it's a it's a couple fold things
this first you know where I really
realized it is after a hell I held the
Texas state record for high school in
the mile and someone broke that a couple
years ago I remember like being there
watching it and then being like no one
cares like doesn't matter like it's just
like me and my head of like hey this
matters like you're a state record
holder like blah blah blah
no one cares a hole I know in a paper
the next yeah wasn't like Steve Magnus
no longer holds exactly but in your head
you blow it up to this big thing so I
think that's that was like the in
catharsis of it but it was really you
know changing my relationship and
getting back to like why I did this
activity in the first place and really
on a from a coaching standpoint that
played a large role because I was
working with you know college kids who
are eighteen to twenty-two who are
enjoying this sport not many of them are
gonna go pro or go to the Olympics or
whatever have you and its really saying
what am I trying to help these kids with
like what what should their relationship
with this sport that they enjoy doing
right and like doing that with other
people really brought it home of like
okay like I'm trying to cultivate this
in them what do I want to cultivate in
myself in a more meta level it's almost
like there's this surface level
dimension where we're all playing this
game where you win you lose you have
success you have recognition and that
stuff feels good when you're in that
game but underneath it there's like this
more like ultimate dimension which is
really about like love right and do you
love the thing that you're doing are you
connected to other people
are you helping them and it can be hard
to exist in both those games at once
so there is nothing wrong with playing
the surface level game and like we
talked about getting excited when you do
well but if you get completely stuck in
that surface level game that's when you
can start to feel Hollow and empty and
the passion goes away yeah it's it's not
a healthy game to play it's not
sustainable and it's not gonna make you
happy and I know that as somebody who's
played that game you know it's very it's
it's it's very alluring to get caught up
in a lot of that kind of statistical
data around how well you're doing with
everything that's available on the
internet now when you put content out
into the world and I'm constantly having
to like remind myself or bring myself
back to the why behind what I'm doing
and I'm as flawed as the next person and
driven by ego and all that kind of stuff
and I'll get like why is it what you
know what I mean and I'm like I have to
it's a practice it's just like a
meditation as a practice okay why am I
doing this what's important about this
it is about connection it is about love
I started this because I love having
these conversations I want to create a
deeper connection with human beings and
everything else around that is just
ephemera yes in that that we say that in
the book over and over that passion is a
practice I think that's another one of
these flaws right so just find your
passion [ __ ] just follow your
passion [ __ ] and be passionate or
like passion is like lightning striking
and then you're passionate like no way
it is an ongoing practice cultivating
nourishing and then coming back to what
matters yeah and and it also involves
doing a bunch of stuff you don't want to
do it's because it's your passion
doesn't mean you like you're stoked
about every single aspect of what's
entailed and pursuing it yeah 100% I
think it I think it goes back to we have
these like false ideas of like what it
looks like and I think it's and it's
almost like the same thing you mentioned
there with this comparison right we
think this is reality over here but it's
not right we think passion means that
like I'm going to enjoy this every
single time that I do this but a lot of
passion is in that grind
and a lot of making something go from
like interest to passion is actually in
the grind of doing mm-hmm yeah I mean
that's something that that everybody
from Gary Vee to David Goggins talks
about like Goggins talks about having to
be you have to be obsessed you know and
you have to do you have to get in the
muck and you know callus the mind and
all that kind of stuff and it's
unbelievably inspirational as much as he
hates that word and would not use it it
is but it's also not necessarily a
recipe for most people because most
people are not going to wake up at 1:30
in the morning to go to the gym do the
things that David does he can set this
example that helps us you know push
through our own personal boundaries and
maybe an incremental way but how do we
find a sustainable propelling fuel in
passion that will allow us to flourish
over the long run versus you know the
unhealthy you know grind until you die
and and I think one of the things that
is almost another nuance part of this is
it's it's not necessarily bad to almost
like go all in for a little bit right
right yeah but it's like having the
awareness to know like all right like to
get this done like I'm gonna have to go
this obsessive go all in
but then I've got to come out of it
unless I want to be down this path of
like I'm gonna be obsessive and I'm
gonna burn out just go all the way and
yeah burning out yeah and that goes to
self awareness which is a big point of
your book I mean you talk about the
illusion of balance we've talked about
this before Brad you've written about
this extensively this is a you know a
subject matter that's super important to
me to this illusion of balance people
saying you should eat a balanced diet
and live a balanced life
I don't adhere to that I think that like
you said it's okay to go all-in but you
have to have the self-awareness to then
pull yourself back out like I talked
about this with Michael Gervais and he
said instead of thinking about balance
just thinking it think about presence
like can you be present in what you're
doing and I think you guys have sort of
gotten at the same idea but you're using
self-awareness yeah I think so what what
we mean by self-awareness
is the ability to see the inertia of
what you're doing and not to let that
inertia Drive you but to make sure that
you're driving ship and again it's
nuanced and it can be hard to tease out
which of those two things it is and that
inertia part of that is from the
external results that we talked about
but part of it is also just because you
really like the thing and it's this
constant practice of looking back and
saying well what am i what am i giving
up as a result to go all in what am i
sacrificing and is it is it worth it and
just asking those questions is helpful
but what we found and what's in the book
is there are some there are some
concrete ways to do this that have been
verified by science that then we've
personally experienced and one of my
favorite is to disconnect and spend time
in nature experience aw and I know in my
own life there is nothing like a day
hike or a backpacking trip that helps me
figure out like okay like what matters
to me like when I come back for that
what am i excited about and I can tell
you it's not checking my Amazon sales
rank it's like spending quality time
with people that I love and writing like
to activities that are completely
unrelated to any external measures
another way to do this that we discuss
in the book is to reflect that mortality
so I really I don't I don't want to use
the word good but a powerful practice
that we recommend is once a year read a
memoir of someone that's in the dyeing
process and coming out of a book like
that for a lot of people it gets really
clear how you how you ought to be
spending your time and whether you want
to call that it's almost like self
awareness is the skill if it lets you be
present for the things that matter the
thing is if you're obsessed you're not
going to allow yourself to go on that
day long hike because you're too
obsessed 100% that's the rub right and
that's why it's that's why we frame this
is it's like these skill sets that you
need to develop because like you know
I've been there before like I've been
totally a hundred percent obsessed all
and forget about everything else
right and anybody can go there but like
what we're trying to get across is hey
like if you can develop these skill sets
of self-awareness of creating a
perspective of giving yourself these
other things to do then you're gonna be
in a better position once that inertia
keeps rolling mmm and you start to go
down that path you can take a you know
divert and take a a different path
I think what happens is somebody is
super passionate about the business that
they're starting or their athletic
pursuits and they may have heard stories
about how people can become too obsessed
and too passionate but they think it
doesn't apply to them that they're gonna
be different right yeah and so whether
it's the woman at Thera knows you know
or you know what happened at Enron Enron
exactly yeah as the other example that
you use in the book we see passion
unleashed in an out-of-control way in
the same way that like it's very similar
to what Ryan talks about an ego that I
mean you know that ego is enemy where
when these things are unchecked things
that we think are positive forces that
are propelling us to succeed ultimately
become our Achilles heel that destroy us
yeah and I think you know I think that's
the important point to make is no one
starts out thinking like I'm gonna be
obsessive and this is gonna be bad right
right everyone starts out I'm like I
enjoy this this is passionate about it
but some people will say I'm gonna
outwork everybody yeah that's nuts how
I'm gonna make it that is true and I cut
but it comes out of a place if I'm gonna
outwork people because this is going to
be good for me right no one thinks that
I'm gonna do this to burn out right and
I think that I think that's why it's
incredibly important to like a cultivate
these skills but also like have people
around you to that to give you that that
check right to put you almost back in
place when you're headed down these
directions
yeah it's you know that out and
sometimes you do need to outwork
everybody like again this this book is
it's a deep dive into nuance like trying
really hard works until it gets in your
way mm-hmm and then the practices well
how to identify when it's getting in
your way well that goes back to the self
awareness piece yeah right yeah so that
seems to be almost the most important
aspect of all of this because if you
lack self awareness or you're just
disconnected from yourself then you're
not going to be able to really navigate
the treacherous waters of figuring this
stuff out I mean if you don't have self
awareness you probably are gonna have
difficulty figuring out what you're
passionate about to begin with yeah the
most important thing you can do is
invest in that personal journey to be
integrated enough so that you can trust
your instincts and and you know have a
kind of reliable Constitution for making
these judgment calls totally but
self-awareness is it's a part of this
passion of practice we think the word
self-awareness so I know myself better
than anyone knows me it's not true no
it's there's there's only some really
neat research that 95% of people are not
self aware is judged by a complete
stranger can better assess their
personality against validated scales
than they could only only about not
surprised
that's his route that's so amazing only
about 5% of people can can do better and
what's really interesting what do they
what is criteria they don't even 95
percent of people are the ones that
think that they're the most self-aware
uh-huh
so it's like this delusional effect that
lots of us what lots of us have I don't
know the exact criteria it's in the book
then there are validated psychological
measures of I think it's personality
like various personality traits and
let's say that you were to go do some
interaction and a stranger were to watch
you and then the stranger rates how you
would fit into these quadrants and then
you rate it
the stranger does better with a trained
psychologist eye on you uh-huh and
that's that's what we've come to coin
like the inertia you don't see clearly
when you're in the midst of all this
inertia so community is huge and people
that you trust because it's one thing to
ask
not really listen it's another thing to
ask someone have them tell you wait a
minute go this way and trust them enough
to do it and then there are things that
you can do as a part of this practice of
passion to develop the ability to see
yourself more clearly
that's fascinating one of the simplest
and very tactical things that we
recommend in the book is pretend that
you're giving advice to a friend and it
sounds like giving advice to yourself
and then give advice to yourself and
this comes up for me all the time in a
very particular way and that is around
my own exercise habits so I tend to
never want to miss workouts and that
will often mean training when I have an
injury and I probably shouldn't mm-hmm
and I will without fail there's two guys
they go to the gym with Scott and Justin
I'll be walking in the gym and I bake if
Scott's biceps tendon was hurting him
and he asked me if he should benchpress
what would I say and the answer is
always do take a week off like you're
fine and I have to ask myself that
question like six times on the way to
the gym and then maybe I won't bench
press but if I don't ask that question
I'm going to the benchpress and that's
just a very concrete example but I think
that that that little twist if you
really imagine someone that could be in
a similar situation than yourself or as
yourself and then ask that question that
can be helpful yeah it's almost more
complicated than simple self-awareness
because you can have the self-awareness
to know that it's not a good idea for
you to bench press but then you're gonna
do it anyway yeah they're still gonna do
it
so there's self-awareness and then
there's the action taken upon that
self-awareness yeah exactly we're almost
working it can't hurt inbuilt cognitive
biases right
I mean we're who were unbelievably like
rudimentary creatures in so many ways
like when you look at the judicial
system and how unreliable witness
testimony is like all these things that
we think we're good at we're absolutely
horrible at exactly and we have a we
have an inbuilt bias to tell a story
that is good for us all right worse no
one wants to sit around and be like oh
I'm a liar cheat etcetera etcetera or
like oh I'm not strong enough to do this
right we have an incentive to tell
ourselves a good story in our head
so it's almost like we need these checks
and balances to make sure that like we
get out of our own way and to react to a
good story like Oh find your passion
like just wait for lightning to strike
and then you'll be happy okay that
sounds good I'm gonna wait for lightning
to strike and when you follow it like
pursue it my mom she sent me this book
well before we were writing this and I
love my mom to death and she's a very
what's the word I'm looking for
just very emotive in a nurturing way and
she had this book of like passion quotes
and of course I pulled it out when I
started on this project and it's like
pursue your passion with reckless
abandon like act as if you couldn't fail
the world is watching and I'm like oh my
gosh that's like you're gonna have a
panic attack that's reading that's
what's out there
because it sounds really nice and then
people end up trapped yeah that's so
funny man
I think it's uh it's it's really it's
really hard and I think we've moved away
from that kind of community integration
that you know for thousands and
thousands of years this is how humans
lived and now we're so fractured right
we're lucky if we have one or two good
friends who knows us well enough to call
us on our [ __ ] because they see us
consistently enough but I think with
that progressive isolation that level of
self-awareness becomes even more for you
know more deeply jeopardized it becomes
more difficult to like really under sea
whether you're you're operating in an
objective way and it's even worse in
today's modern society right because
we're going to project an image on
Instagram or right exactly or wherever
it is right so we're almost in like the
habit in business
yeah of projecting how we want to be so
not only do we have to deal with our own
delusions but now we're creating them
and there's an expectation yeah exactly
and and then yeah just like the writing
like how do I live up to this you know
image that I've crafted for myself yeah
it's tough it's not good right no it
doesn't feel good
you know in it and that's again that's
that's part of the practice of passion
is to be vulnerable and to build
community and to have people that you
trust and that all leads to harmonious
passion versus the obsessive passion is
this I've got it all together I'm
bulletproof
I can't fail and then what happens Steve
said there's this identity fusion and
then when you do fail well it's not just
the thing failed its you failed mm-hmm
and then suddenly lying becomes more of
a temptation acting unethical there's
there's some research that we profile in
the book that athletes who use steroids
are so much more likely to so I'll step
back there there's this model developed
by a psychologist named Robert Valery
and and it's a survey that lets you
answer questions and it will tell you
you're obsessive or harmonious and we're
in the spectrum you fall because it's
not black or white there's a direct
correlation with people that fall in the
obsessive side and steroids and sport
and unethical behavior in business hmm
and it makes total sense because again
if the thing that you're passionate
about is the result and your identity is
tied to that result you're gonna and the
result doesn't happen you're gonna do
anything to get the result because as
Steve so often says it's no longer an
attack on your business it's an attack
on you yeah yeah yeah and when we're
talking about it it sounds so clear but
it's when you're in it and you're doing
the thing it's this really slippery
slope and sometimes without self
awareness it can happen and you don't
know what's happening that you're going
from harmonious to obsessive will you
see this on the day-to-day - right
how many times have you gotten in it in
an argument with a friend or your spouse
or your boyfriend or girlfriend and like
you go into that defensive mode where
it's like oh they're attacking me yeah
and it's not about the argument in
anymore it's about like you winning this
so that like your ego can or in your
sense of self can that's like that's
like every you know political argument
or or kind of the diet wars that you see
we've talked about this too it's become
like so tribal and polarized like I just
don't even want to be part of that
whatsoever I really write because it's
you know people so self-identify with
their tribe that any any kind of cogent
objective discussion is impossible
because it is so personalized so an
attack against this idea or argument or
perspective becomes an attack on who you
are as a human being and that of course
is going to make you defensive exactly
and and that pushes us more into our own
tribe right yeah exactly yeah and then
on social media you signal to that tribe
to make sure that they know that you're
a member in good standing of that so
like those arguments are about making
sure that you're affirming your
membership in that group much more so
than they are about changing the minds
of somebody who's outside of that group
totally one one one practice coming back
to the example and particularly that
because again this stuff can make sense
intellectually but then it's hard and
actually act on one practice that we we
recommend in the book that we heard from
just about everyone that we interviewed
that has had a long career and stayed
harmoniously passionate is this notion
very swiftly returning to the work
itself so if you have a huge success as
a writer celebrate the success because
there's something to say about
celebration and joy that's important but
then don't take too long before you get
back to writing and the same thing after
a failure like it's okay to be sad and
to grieve a defeat but then get back to
the thing itself because in the case of
a victory getting back to the thing is
humbling and in the case of a defeat
getting back to the thing is like why
really like I like this thing you know
I'm doing it because of the activity not
because of the results and it literally
it prevents your brain from grooving in
those neural pathways that are
associated with validation bestseller
Olympic medal its nope running like back
to the activity this is what I like and
in the case of defeat same thing you're
short-circuiting
brains process to really hardwire all
these negative emotions or I'm a failure
and then that just builds more pressure
for the next time it's again note back
to the act right so you're reinforcing
process as being the endgame as opposed
to the results of that process being the
determining factor and how you feel
about what you do yeah because the
results are there so transient if you
think like we spend our life in the
process the amount of time that you look
at the New York Times thing and see your
book is a best-seller is one second yeah
but then you can spend years thinking
about it or being bummed out that you
missed it in like like your friend Mike
drove ASA not really present for your
life and there's something about getting
back to the thing that doesn't let that
that delusional not even delusional book
that being elsewhere worrying about
success or failure take root in your
brain yeah and let's just be honest
that's very hard because listen if
you're gonna open up the New York Times
and you're gonna see that your book is
listed on that special list that they
make in that newspaper once in a while
that is intoxicating
right and that's something that's going
to get you excited and also it's going
to lie to you it's gonna tell you that
this is what's gonna change your life
this is what's gonna make you feel okay
this is what's me this is why it's all
worth it etc all of that which is an
illusion of course that you don't
realize until you experience it and
understand you don't feel any different
about your life what is that what does
that sound as you described that where
we started eerily like it's like
addiction mm-hmm right like that's the
paseo that's the suffering so you know
you said his passion good or bad and I'm
like it depends well that kind of
passion might feel good just like your
next hit feels good but ultimately that
leads to suffering because it's
constantly craving and once it goes away
you're miserable whereas the but if you
love writing then you're like this is
awesome this just means I get to do this
more yes but then get back to the work
don't sit there talking about how you're
a New York Times best selling author be
proud of yourself don't minimize the
success but then like ass in the chair
start writing if you're an Olympic
medalist you got to get paid like go do
the media spots but on the track I guess
in this case its feet on the track start
running and same thing in business
really
accesible executives are the executives
that do the work not the executives that
talk about the work and at the
executives that you know go on TV about
the work they're the ones that do the
work mm-hmm and all the science that you
guys reviewed right in this book what
was what were some of the more
surprising findings that you came across
as it relates to passion I got one then
so there's that there's um a neuro
psychiatrist named Mark Lewis and his
work around what happens when you're in
the throes of an obsessive passion shows
that it's very similar to individuals
suffering from eating disorders whoa
because when someone's suffering from an
eating disorder when they look in the
mirror they don't necessarily see
someone that is too thin and sick they
see someone that is too big and it's the
same brain activity when someone is in
the throes of an obsessive passion so
their company may be failing they may be
ruining their marriage they may be lying
to the feds but they don't they don't
see all any of that they just see like
we're on this mission got to succeed
just like the person with an eating
disorder has got to lose more weight and
that's that that's that's that linkage
again that's passion right in the case
of the the not the person with the
eating disorder you can say an eating
disorder is passion about losing weight
yeah to the UM can be very passionate
about destroying your life yeah you can
be very passionate about being a victim
all those things are true so so the the
the when the idea came together we
started like these are interesting
concepts to explore but then the science
really drilled at home that like passion
suffering it's one coin and it's often
about where where you direct it another
example that's similar is if you think
about the act of training for the
Olympics to swim you were a swimmer six
to eight hours a day in the pool maybe I
don't know maybe there's some land work
so you are staring in a line in water to
the exclusion of everything in your life
for six to eight hours a day and when
you're not in the pool you're probably
thinking about your workout that sounds
a lot like OCD like
obsession is Olympics and training and
the compulsion as you swim but it's
pointed in a positive direction and I
think Olympic athletes are awesome and
super inspirational but what we want to
do is we want to point out like this
stuff just isn't so simple it's insanity
it is insanity right so we're very you
know in in the way that we're selective
about which animals we love and which
animals we eat were selective about
which obsessions we socially approve of
in which we decide our addictions that
we need to malign it is the gift of say
one last thing about because the OCD
part in particular the closest thing
then it's still a world away but the
closest thing I can describe to my brain
when it's in the storm of OCD is my
brain when I'm writing because it's just
like I'm locked into the book like it
feels somewhat similar I could be at the
dinner table but I'm thinking about the
book I could be at the gym but I'm
thinking about the book it's just and
I'm obsessed with it and that is a great
gift and I really like writing but it's
that same brain chemistry that if it's
pointed in another direction you know
can Rio or I so there's this notion of
there's there's at least I think that
there's two ways to go about it
there's realizing that your temperament
is as such I'm pointing that in positive
directions well and at the same time
there's working on self-awareness and
skills to be able to turn that off when
you want to and to be able to choose to
yeah and I think you know that's the
kind of greater thing that we noticed in
this book is it's it's all this stuff is
on a spectrum right it's not good or bad
if you look at Olympic athletes like
when they're done with the Olympics and
on their break let's say they exhibit
the exact same symptoms as an addict
getting taken off drugs right no
depression anxiety all those things
happen and the same thing you know
talking with Brad a little bit is
actually growing up like I had OCD I
just didn't know I had it so I had all
these compulsions so I'd have to touch
doorknobs or else I thought I was gonna
like something bad was gonna happen
turn my alarm on and off seven times
with
I went to bed or else I thought I'd wake
up dead stuff like that and those were
all in retrospect looking back oriented
around running performance why not
originally but a ritualistic we all
ritualists right
and but like as I grew up or as I grew
into running like I just directed all of
those like rituals and obsessions
towards running uh-huh so running the
training for running itself became
obsessive-compulsive it was like I have
to go out for this run or else like I'm
gonna have these horrible anxiety etc
that's overwhelming so I'm gonna go out
for this run so I think when we look at
that and if I look at other athletes
that I've helped out like if you look at
a lot of Lamar on that spectrum of
having some sort of obsession and
compulsion to have to do it yeah I mean
you almost have to have some degree if
you're gonna go out and run I don't know
120 miles a week right yeah I mean I've
I've manifested certain aspects of that
I mean I relate to that a lot like I
would have to be the first person to
arrive for a morning workout like I like
little you know just things that are
meaningless but work to me is like oh I
wasn't the first one here and then I had
a certain way I had to wash my bathing
suit like after I was done that had to
be done in a certain way it was
completely OCD and insane right
but you trick yourself into thinking
that these are related to ultimately
your performance later on exactly it's
that like inner mind game where you're
like no I have to do this because this
this is going to help me performer this
is good this is why I'm good at this and
if I don't do this ritual if I don't
follow this and I'm not gonna be good at
and if somebody sorry go ahead what I
was just gonna say in in that sense it's
almost like accepted right because it's
like oh this is prison
yeah we we tie it up into like oh that
person's just really passionate about
running he's just super driven and super
intrinsically driven like I don't have
if you were asked to coach or if you
were asked to ask my coach at that time
like I don't have to worry about him
he's gonna do his work out he's gonna
get everything done and it's all in this
positive light but if we frame those
same behaviors in a different context
we live be like oh that's negative that
person needs this help and this this
person if we go to do this so as
somebody who lived through that and who
now coaches how do you counsel your
athletes when you start to see indicia
of this kind of OCD behavior yeah that's
a good question you know one of the
things that I try and do is is starting
with that awareness and understanding of
what they're doing and if this behavior
is like almost if they're in control of
it or not because I think the biggest
thing I saw with myself is that over
time it's almost like these OCD
behaviors took control right where if
you didn't do them then like extreme
anxiety etc etc and that's the definite
real quick that's the definite like
clinical OCD the definition is like you
totally lose control and it's just
non-stop 24/7 so I think it's important
to say like these these to me these are
still on spectrums because I've always
been super ritualistic but then like for
16 hours a day like it when I was in the
thick of it if I was sitting here I'd
look at that glass and be like oh I
could just like jab that into my neck
and then massive anxiety well so it's
it's I just want to be clear because I
I've become really cautious about like
using those terms but I do think that
it's still the same spectrum because
it's the same thing it's just that this
isn't a way or maybe it's two hours a
day and then pathologically it's just
non-stop
okay sorry Steve Iceland yeah that way I
mean it's and I think it's not all on
this extremes right it's like growing up
like even outside of the running context
like I had a different OCD classified
behaviors right but I wasn't going to
sit there and wash like I didn't have it
so bad that I was going to wash dishes
for two hours right or wash my hands you
know walk around in a circle for 10
hours you can see exactly and that I
think that's where it's really important
to see this spectrum and I think that's
what's really important about human
nature is I don't know about other you
know mental health issues but I imagine
they're all along these different
spectrums and then just in that let ik
world you know people who maybe are
mildly on this spectrum have channeled
it into this
thing right so we've accepted it as yeah
we reinforced it right we celebrate yeah
actually
exactly and a lot of sports they do and
a lot of coaches actually do they'll
reinforce like oh that worked last time
like keep doing this ritualistic
behavior and then it spirals and can
spiral out of but if you can control it
in the outcome is positive then I think
it's a good thing like David Goggins you
just had on your show he is a super
disciplined creature of routine at least
it sounds like it and he seems to be
loving it and enjoying life and
inspiring people so maybe that's not a
problem and again it's like this while
it's the gift in the curse it depends on
where it's pointed maybe it even depends
on at what point in your life you're at
right if you're doing certain behaviors
when you've got two little kids at home
maybe that is harmful whereas if you
don't have to look at it's great so it's
these kind of nuanced things right and
Steve as a coach though when you do see
athletes starting to demonstrate this
kind of stuff like what is the what is
the path to getting them to snap out of
it or or developing some greater self
awareness around
yeah actually going I think it depends
on actually how severe the issue is
right if it's just little things here
and there like you make them aware of it
and you say like hey like let's you know
if it's not a big deal
let's try this race over here in this
safe environment without doing this and
without tying your shoes six times in a
row yeah like when I went through
therapy that's basically it like you
expose yourself to the thing that you're
scared of without reassuring you're so
low risk environment not not at the big
no no risk and I think that's that's the
thing is you're trying to get you know I
call it like you're gonna feel this
almost like anxiety from it because it's
like your ritual but what I want them to
get used to is just to sit with it right
and if you can have the ability to like
just sit with that and understand and
see it like come and let go when nothing
happens and you raced fine and all that
good stuff then you can get out of that
but you know on the same side like I've
had athletes who have exhibited
behaviors that further along in the
spectrum there and I think that's where
it's almost what you need
bring preferring professional
then right because if it starts
infiltrating other aspects of their life
or starts infiltrating or interfering
with you know making it we're running
and racing is no longer something that
is enjoyed but instead something that
like okay I have to go through this and
do this and do this and do this just to
get on the starting line and then I
don't really enjoy doing this but it's
the only thing I've done in my
identity's wrapped around it around it
so I'm gonna continue doing that yeah
it's an example of passion turning
malignant like it saw it almost becomes
this cancerous growth as opposed to this
you know beautiful sustaining force
exactly hundred percent and one of the
things we talk about when we talk about
passion is how to find it how to find
your passion then how to chase it how to
chase your passion and how to live your
passion but what we don't talk about is
when it's time to let go of your passion
and move on with your life right and
that's that might be my favorite chapter
in your book by just bringing this up
and using examples of other people like
who have come to this place of deciding
like hey I know that my identity was
wrapped up in this but it's time to do
something different so can you guys talk
a little bit about that yeah I mean I'm
gonna let Steve take this first because
I think Steve directly experienced it
with himself and running mm-hmm yeah
sure
I mean I think it's it's almost like you
have to come to peace with that right
you have to come to terms and peace with
whatever you're doing and having like
the awareness that this isn't just this
isn't the only thing I am this isn't the
only only person I am and goes back to
the identity piece right and you have to
come to terms with that before moving on
to the next thing and I think it's
really hard you know on an athletic
level especially because if you look at
athletes when are they done in their 20s
maybe if they're lucky their 30s right
and they've spent their entire lives
like building towards this thing and
wrapping yourself around this one thing
and then you get to the point where most
people are building their careers and
you have to like injures and then all
the sudden you're like the 22 year old
out of college figuring out okay what's
now what's the meaning gonna like where
am I gonna get with the snap of a
fingers it's over overnight and so many
athletes find themselves thinking for
the very first time about what might
come next because they're training their
whole life around the pursuit of
excellence in their sport is so
all-consuming there almost isn't any
room for entertaining what's going to
come after yeah and it's in sport in
itself like is very good at giving you
like this end goal and this purpose and
this definitive thing to shoot for well
life is kind of nebulous two-degree huh
right we have to make those decisions
ourselves when we're in sport like those
decisions are kind of made for us yeah
so it's kind of like you know it's in
the military exactly yeah
so I think it takes a lot of work and I
think in the sporting front like you
need more work on on preparing people to
make that transition and you know they
have the skill set needed but no one
tells you how to like find something or
how to you know direct your purpose and
drive to something new and different
yeah I mean it's it's it's a huge
problem you know I think that that the
NC 2a or every college every you know
sporting Federation should have
something set up to help athletes
transition out of their sports to make
it a more graceful entryway into the
workforce I've seen I experienced this
myself like I wasn't even that good and
I had like you know a major existential
crisis it's like a mourning it's like a
funeral when you finally say I'm gonna
put this away and I'm going to do
something else and you know what makes
it worse is you know that you have this
ability to dedicate yourself to work
incredibly hard to you know to endure
suffering like all of these
characteristics
you think would translate into the
workforce and be valued but if you're
disconnected from what it is that you
might be interested in or good at
because you've never really thought
about it then it's hard to figure out
you know how to you know find the round
hole for the round peg yeah and you end
up like there's a lot of people that
struggle with drugs and alcohol and all
these kinds of problems because they
don't know what to do and there's nobody
there everyone just has been they've
been on the cover of magazines for like
a decade and then suddenly there are
civilian and they're like okay go be an
accountant you don't know you know we we
talked about our cultivating your
passion via dabbling in interests well
in college if you're an athlete you know
this well like if you don't give time to
dabble in any other interests right it's
go to class and like you know go to
practice and compete and all that stuff
you know athletes at the college level
like they don't get to do the
internships or these other things a lot
a year abroad exactly to find things
that like hey this might be worthwhile
pursuing so I think like you know we
could talk about the pros all day but I
think that the college level from
transitioning from you know 21 22 year
old kid then to the workplace is it's
almost heartbreaking right because you
have all these kids so you know the
administration at college athletics
athletic directors say hey go represent
us like go get on the magazine's go get
on the TV go get this publicity and then
you know most of you aren't gonna make
it professional but you're gonna have to
figure out something and then you're
gonna be like oh yeah I have this degree
in something that I took just so that I
could stay eligible and have this degree
but like I don't really know need or
know what I can do
yeah and what also happens is that at
least speaking personally there's almost
a sense of shame because you're you know
what it's like to feel so plugged into
something and passionate and driven and
direct it and then suddenly that gets
taken away you can't do that anymore but
the bar is set so high in terms of
what's going to get you excited about
getting out of bed
the morning and the chances that you're
gonna find a job that's going to give
you that are pretty low well right well
just think of you know yeah
compare the adrenaline that you hope
Amin of all that of racing like you know
a pac-12 championship or it's double le
a championship versus going and saying
hey like I'm the lowest level like
accountant at this this company right
there is no you don't get that hit I
mean play it out in a sport where you
know you can't really pursue a living
but perhaps you're the best in the world
at it like you guys you get an Olympic
yeah you get an Olympic gold medal in
fencing you're the best fencer in the
whole world but then I mean I guess you
could go like be in the movies like sort
of teach people how to sword fight in
movie I don't know but you're not gonna
be able to be a professional fencer and
support yourself so you're gonna have to
join the work force like how are you
gonna do that and do it gracefully and
do it in a way where you feel good about
the new path that you're gonna be
blazing for yourself I mean that is a
very tall order and if you're doing that
alone which you probably are because
there's nobody there saying hey we know
this is gonna be really rough like let
me help you it's a disaster waiting to
happen so I think that the the there
there is no easy answer as Steve said
it's really hard I think something that
hopefully this book in this conversation
leads to more conversation is just
around transition at a sport
particularly at collegiate levels and
how awful it is in like the human
suffering that results from this
particularly and I'm gonna go off-topic
a little but like these kids aren't paid
either hmm so like it's really pretty
much a heist right unless you're the
half-a-percent sure makes it is a pro so
that just pisses me off but anyways I
think that there needs to be more help
along the way in cultivating some other
interest and also helping people to see
that what you do develop is a collegiate
athlete is the ability to go all-in on
something and that is a function can be
applied in different areas so coming out
of school you might not have the the
skills to go work in finance or
consulting or writing
but you certainly have the work ethic
and I'd almost argue that the discipline
and the work ethic can be harder to
cultivate than the skill so imagine if
there were these transition out of sport
programs where you had someone to work
with you to identify certain areas at
which you could put use that drive and
and that would be successful and there
are pilot programs that work with
athletes to do just that and it's really
geared around entrepreneurship because
it's the same kind of attitude they're
like you're representing yourself and
like you're going all in but those
programs are pilots and I think that
they need to be the norm or at least
something like that and rather than be
like you are a runner now go get a job
it's you are a driven person that knows
how to channel that drive mm-hmm you can
apply that to anything let's find
something that you like yeah I think
it's important to I think what you said
is really important the piece about
recognizing the the how do I want to say
this the self-control like the idea that
an athlete is self-directed but that
dictates that in the work force they
need to feel a sense of ownership and
direction over the path that they're
taking like the athlete no I know how
what to do for myself to get this
performance out of myself and I'm
responsible for putting in the work and
then I'm responsible for the result is
very different from being the lowest
rung on a team where you're you're
completely disempowered yeah you know
which is the the exact opposite of what
that athlete journey is all there's I'm
not saying that very no you're saying as
well there's there's a really there's a
neat company it's called valor perform
and it's a small start-up the woman that
founded at her she's awesome her name's
Sarah mill B she played soccer at
Wisconsin I think B beam I was
constantly she played college soccer and
the whole business is built on we're
gonna take former pro in high level
collegiate athletes and have them work
in this this bálor perform more than
they're helping businesses I'm coaching
on performance so this company is like a
year and a half old so it'll be really
interesting to follow but a huge part of
the mission
is to only recruit former athletes and
then design an organization that is not
a big bureaucracy but that lets people
have autonomy and control and push and
it's an experiment I don't know how it
will turn out but I think the ideas like
that are really good and useful because
I'm around elite athletes all the time
not as often as Steve but like you don't
have to be a coach to know like these
people are really driven and if you
point them at something they'll be great
and they can enjoy it because they love
doing the work the problem you just is
that like you abandon them on this
Islands and you don't point them at
anything and then what ends up happening
is they get a job in a big bureaucracy
and to both of your point like that
can't compare right I would also
encourage any athlete who's listening to
this collegiate athlete or or otherwise
to take a tip from what you guys said
earlier which is this is not like
finding your passion isn't like the love
of your life kind of thing like you can
have multiple passions and just because
you're all in on your sport and it
doesn't even have to be sports it could
be whatever it it just because you're
all in on one thing doesn't mean that
you've crowded out all the space to be
interested in something else so try to
cultivate a side hustle passion you know
at the same time so that you are
planting those seeds for what your
future like might become so a great
example of that is there's Olympic
swimmer named Tyler Clary who's like now
getting into stock car racing like
racecar driving which is something he
was kind of doing I'm sure he I don't
know enough about it but I'm sure he's
been doing it for a very long time
probably love doing it as a kid and but
he's he's developed some skill and some
relationships and some acumen in that
world when he was still competing and
racing and swimming and now he's
stepping out and like he's ready to like
for this new chapter right it's almost
like you're paving the way for that
along the way so try to bear that in
mind
while you're still pursuing that you
know ultimate like super passion and I
think that gets that that
almost misnomer that like in order to be
great at something you have to be a
hundred percent all in which I don't
think holds true right it's well you're
doing that swimming let's say okay be
all in that practice but then you have
all this other time of the day
which you can utilize some portion of it
to pursue other things that are
interesting that won't take away from
swimming and I think it's almost like
this ego thing where we think like oh if
I'm gonna be the best writer in the
world then I only need to write yeah and
it has to be like this and this is all
like we know Kisan i know i
if that was true though then the best
athletes would all be like people that
live in the woods around where there's
no people around them and the best
writers would be people who have no
relationships with it you know what I
mean it doesn't work that way
right in Steve's point with the swimming
example thinking about swimming is not
the same thing as swimming yeah like
when you're in class when you're hanging
out with like thinking about swimming
know that like if anything I'm just
gonna get in your ear when you're you
know 21 22 yeah you can live in a dorm
room and swim like six hours a day and
whatever free time you have you can play
video games and you could do that for a
while but you can't be a professional
swimmer at age 30 and still be doing
that exact you know what I mean and this
is something I talked with Kerri
walsh-jennings about like how do you
Olympics after Olympics after Olympics
after Olympics
okay now you're married and now you have
kids it's easy to look at that and say
well that's distracting me from being
the greatest volleyball player of all
time but to mature into a place where
you recognize and value the fact that
that's actually making you a better
athlete because it's making you a more
grounded well-rounded person is a
maturation process that is
counterintuitive but absolutely drew you
you you just said that so better than I
would have said it and I was thinking
the exact same thing which is like over
time is you age - I think that there's a
you gain some wisdom and you know you
say a maturation process that's exactly
what it is
I know for so also to call timeout when
we're giving it
vice to these collegiate kids it's
really hard I often catch myself
thinking about the book the book release
writing when I'm not writing the book
so it's an again it's a practice so it's
not like oh you now just like turn off
the switch doesn't work like that you
have to constantly be practicing coming
back the maturation process I now have a
kid he's ten months old
nothing has been better for my ability
to be present than Theo mm-hmm because
like he's just there it's awesome
mm wasn't like that the first three
months but now that he's doing stuff and
he's like a little dude um but it it's
hard to put into words and it sounds so
cliche but I've noticed that it's not
that the other stuff seems less
important it almost feels more important
but also much easier to turn off and
step away from if that makes sense
and maybe it's just another passion
right and like parenting and having that
relationship but I do think that as you
add more to your life it actually is all
additive it doesn't necessarily take
away from the thing you're doing yeah
and you have to get more clear on what
it is you're doing and how you're doing
it because you don't have as much luxury
when it comes to time oh well yeah the
advice of these college kids like go
have a child no it's like it's like a
living it's like a little living Zen
master is like your writing and he
cracks the whip and it's like okay um I
mean I've been on the phone with Steve I
don't know many times and it's like up
Theo just pooped in the bath like I go
yeah this ingenious idea will have to
wait all right you guys well we got a UH
we got to wrap this up but I wanna I
want to do that by exploring your
personal definition of passion for
yourself right so so Steve if I'm to say
like well explain to me you're pickin
you articulate to me your relationship
with passion and what that looks like
yeah so I see it I think it's important
to understand that it's not black and
white
okay so I see it as for the majority of
time I want to have a healthy harmonious
relationship with passion uh-huh but I
also want the ability or the ability to
go deep and to go all-in on things but
where I see my relationship right now is
I have the awareness to understand when
I'm doing that and to pull back out of
that when I need to I like that but what
is it that you're passionate about can
you put a pin on that can I put a bit so
I I guess now like this might be a
little cliche and maybe not super clear
but I like pursuing interesting ideas so
whether it's in coaching and looking at
how to help athletes get faster whether
it's in writing and you know getting
these ideas on passion or in peak
performance out there it's exploring
interesting ideas that are intriguing
enough to me to say hey I want to
understand this at like a deep level so
that hopefully I can convey that
information to others to help them
understand these things you know maybe
even better than I do
I like that answer I thought you were
gonna say I mean the obvious answer is
I'm passionate about running I'm
passionate about writing I'm passionate
about helping young athletes achieve
their potential but you really brought
in the aperture on it yeah you know I
think that's maybe that that maturation
you talked about you know if you asked
me three four years ago I would have
given you that answer but as I've like
branched out and have all these
different interests in different places
I think that's the common theme tying
them together whether it's on like a
personal one-to-one basis of working
with an athlete or whether it's on a
basis of you know one book you know
thousands of people it's all kind of
similar of getting these ideas and
trying to help people change and develop
and grow
that's right act to follow yeah the
question is Pat with passion what does
that mean to me yeah yeah I mean look
guys wrote this book about passion so
how youth how do you think and apply
passion in your own life so like how do
you define that in is it I guess a you
know a question on top of that is is it
important to define it for yourself and
be clear about what you're passionate
about and what that means so I think
that the way that I well I think the
question is in two fold right it's how
does one define passion and then how
important is it to constantly be clear a
working definition that just jotted this
down that that I have is it's really
caring about something knowing that that
thing might eventually break your heart
mm-hmm because you have to move on from
it or the tides change and being okay
with it in doing it anyways however let
me just interrupt you there yes in the
athletic context but if you're no I'd
say in any context I mean if you're a
guitar player or somebody you something
that you could do your whole life
yeah but parent okay so I'm thinking
parenting like eventually my kids gonna
move out hopefully like that might be
heartbreaking and even guitar I'd
imagine there's a point like where the
skills start to fade with age maybe not
it can be that's a good example but
you're gonna have let downs like the
more that you care about something the
higher the highs and the lower Veloz and
still pursuing that those things anyways
in doing it though with the
self-awareness - Steve sad no one to
choose when like I need to pivot here
and then also having community
underneath you because the community
helps keep you grounded during those
highs and helps support you during those
lows yeah and I think that the community
and the bonds that come out of a passion
is almost as powerful as the passion
itself because it's in those
relationships like that's what gives the
life meaning mm-hmm it's part of the
reason we might put together is it's a
lot of fun and it's a beautiful
relationships formed and for the person
who's out there who is struggling to
identify their passion and we talked
about this a little bit earlier but like
what what are some steps that you can
recommend for that person to begin the
journey or the process of trying to
connect with something meaningful that
could blossom into how we think about
passion yeah I I would just keep it
really simple
yeah is go dabble and thanks mm-hmm so
part yourself inside your comfort zone
outside your comfort zone look at
different things that you know you might
think like hey this is kind of
interesting as you pointed out earlier
like go to your childhoods like what
were the things that like you would do
when there was nothing else to do when
you're just like okay I'm letting go do
this for a couple hours
right finding different things that were
interesting or are interesting to you
those are all potential passions right
there is no one like this is the one all
of those things are are potentially
passions and the only way you understand
if they can like have that fan flame to
turn into like that burning passion that
we all know and think about is if you
try them and try them a lot and see if
it cultivates into that if it has
staying power right actly I think we all
have a lot of self judgment around these
things like well that's silly or stupid
I shouldn't do that
you know but I think so I think it's
important to remove that veil of
judgment over yourself like hey maybe
you should you know maybe it would be
cool for you to be a puppeteer or like I
don't you know whatever it is like if
that's your thing man like right we're
totally in and I'm so glad that you do
the puppeteer example I think of my
uncle Bob he's a financial adviser a
stockbroker for 60 years
you know black suit red tie and now he
makes beaded jewelry uh-huh and like
that's his thing fine like you don't
know you don't need to you don't need to
like decide that you're going to be in a
rock band like make beaded jewelry
um again you know don't be reckless be
financially responsible but yeah like
there's no there's no definition of
success that you should shoot for and if
anything if you are shooting for some
definition of success as we've discussed
like you're probably setting yourself up
for pain and suffering right so
conversely the next question is if you
are somebody who's blazing a path
passion what are the warning signs to
alert you that perhaps your passion has
become a little bit unhealthy when the
when the pursuit of results starts to
become the dominating factor and not
when it's a factor because again unless
you've done like extensive spiritual
training and dissolved your ego like
it's always going to be a factor but
when it starts becoming the dominating
factor when it's hard to get back to
doing the work or when the work itself
no longer feels good when the work feels
like a chore because you're chasing the
thing mmm I think that that's one prime
example and then another prime example
is when you notice the temptation to cut
corners work to cheat that is a sign
that like you no longer have
self-control and if you're listening and
you're there don't judge yourself that's
great you have self-awareness you're
there like course-correct
you know read the book get a therapist
talk to a friend because recognizing
that is actually great because you've
recognized it it's when you don't
recognize it you get into trouble right
give anything out of that Steve those
were great I don't think I can top them
yeah yeah yeah in the in the writing of
the book was there anything that you
came across in the research or the
interviews of all the people that you
spoke with that was it odds with your
thesis going in to realize like weird
thing and maybe it's good maybe it's bad
maybe it's both and presumably there's a
way to live with it well yeah and I
think I think one of the things that was
interesting about this book is going
back to being like the way this came
about was Brad and I sitting in a coffee
shop
all right saying hey this first book is
done like we don't have anything to do
on this for a month and like we're here
together for a week like what are we
gonna do so we just started these
conversations and talking about it so
it's not like we went in with any grand
thesis or grand idea it started as hey
this is interesting yeah and then the
writing on the page so like in our
relation
ship-like I'd say Steve is primary
scientist I'm primary writing and then
we switch so Steve's like off doing
science and this is before peak
performance without and I'm going to the
same coffee shop every single day and
like writing stories as if I'm writing
this book and then I'm like Steve I've
written a bunch and Steve's like dude I
have this enormous outline of science
and then we got together and like we
traded and suddenly like there's a bull
squirrel but we know really you're right
we did not set out to write a book on
passion yeah we just were doing what
felt like we had this time and space we
were doing what felt natural and then it
became a book and I think the other part
is we were it's very meta yeah because
it's like look this thread of passion to
write this book about passion and you
did it in the right way because your
intention was anatomists and and again
back to like the no one has their [ __ ]
figured out it has helped me I know it's
not like I no longer care about success
I care a lot about success it's helped
me be aware when I'm caring too much
about that and it's given me the writing
of the book is giving me some practices
to rein that in right yeah and also call
each other on right yeah now that we
know this stuff it's like you're like
hey you're manifesting symptoms of this
yeah yeah
or just were the opposite like I mean
this might be the the OCD tendency in me
is I get so in my head I'm calling Steve
and like dude am i tweeting too much
like is my passion obsessive like am I
getting too excited about doing this
ritual podcast is like dude - right so
like yeah we're not saying don't enjoy
things like enjoy things celebrate them
but just like you know 51% harmonious
and enjoy the success to you because
like it's fleeting but it's fun when you
have it right and it's amorphous trying
to kind of figure out how to think about
these ideas that all bump into each
other like you know the idea of balance
like what is balance is balance
overrated I mean that's a conversation
you know we had years ago right right
and these are like how does that relate
to passion and what is the value of
passion and what Trump's the other right
anything is it's all this murky soup
yeah right and it is
spectrum and that's not a gratifying
answer in in you know a culture in which
we want the very clear-cut life hack and
you know the simple thing that we can
like hang our hat on yeah we're you know
our publisher and agent probably on our
aren't happy with us for not having that
single simple hook that's like one idea
but like that's what we're trying to
deal with reality right in all these
conversations that we've had that Brad
and I have had like they're just things
we're wrestling with and that's why this
is such an interesting thing is passion
is this big blob of amorphous stuff that
mixes together and there's no correct
like hack to figure it out it's just
what we realized in this is that there's
a lot of different ways to do it but
just kind of be aware of what you're
getting into
uh-huh you know if you want to go all-in
great do it but like be aware that
you're doing it right this is what's
this is this is the this is what's
entailed in this journey yeah yeah and
if you stay in it too long then you know
this and this might happen but if you
have the self-awareness to understand
like hey this is good you know this is
this is how you excel like you have to
go all-in on something that you're
passionate about
that's how greatness is created across
every discipline but you know you need
to know when to pull out as well and
recalibrate yeah yeah ever enough and I
want to know Steve in the researching of
this book and the writing of this book
how has this impacted your coaching
downstream like I asked you specifically
about one thing earlier but like in
general has this informed like your
coaching philosophy or how you interact
with your athletes a hundred percent it
has mmm I mean it's made me you know
actually I was reading a book by Percy
Sarah Dee who was a great coach in the
1960s and his book was all in there he
talked all about how intrinsic
motivation mattered but more than
anything he said I'm training and
coaching you to be a better person and
if you're a better person than you will
run faster and I think
with this passion thing it's very
similar as I'm trying to now my
perspective has changes like the
performance will take care of itself
right is if we do these workouts and do
all this stuff like we're gonna get
better but the greater good on this is
how do we make you have a better
relationship with like this activity
that you're putting so much effort into
so I see my almost goal now is like how
do I cultivate this like ability for
them to have a healthy or a good
relationship with with running and with
themselves exactly parents if you're
listening send your kids to Steve also
like coaches need to yeah you should you
should be coaching coaches about how to
be better coaches for for you know
people's lives as opposed to performance
like the workout is easy that's the
easiest part right it's all the messy
psychology of like dealing with young
people in their formative years exactly
it's funny as a coach you get trained in
the workouts in the physiology but you
get no or little training in a
psychology but that's what matters the
most and you know the funny thing is if
you look at coaches like we probably
have at the high school and college
level you see your coach more often than
you see anybody else right so the
ability to impact a kid is much greater
for me than some you know math or
science professor or anybody else and
that responsibility like that's pretty
big yeah and same when you look at you
know Brad brought up parents but like
parents have a huge impact on all this
stuff I've seen so many kids come to the
collegiate level who have an unhealthy
relationship with the sport because you
know mom and dad like they're a kid it
can't be their fault at that age yeah
mom and dad put this pressure in these
expectations and you know this is how
this works and you better do this and it
just creates this unhealthy relationship
which then I have to unravel yeah how do
you unraveled our
that that's like the military that might
be a our there yeah but it's so
important you know and I think it is
true there's there's no barrier to entry
essentially to anybody saying they're a
coach I mean obviously there's
certifications and things you know all
that kind of stuff but the fact that the
psychological aspect of it which is the
gravamen of what you're doing is
something that that is not trained at
all is insane oh it's it's crazy I mean
it's it's completely backwards and
something that should be see and
slightly more remove than Steve looking
in there's also this perverse incentive
especially in college where what is good
for the kid might what is good for the
kid over 20 years might not be good for
the kid its performance over four years
so it's like chasing quarterly profits
instead of long-term growth right and
it's real easy for a college coach we
talked about this in our first book to
burn the crap out of a kid kid runs
great in college and then the kids first
Pro me there's nothing left in his or
her legs and they're done or it's you
know not even a pro mean it's like you
burn them for four years and then they
have a horrible relationship with the
sport and never want to do it again do
it yeah and then you have this
resentment in this whole other
psychology that it's there we got a lot
of problems ago so practice your hands
right it is a positive it's a positive
book but I think yeah it addresses
something that there's a lot of delusion
around and says hey like it's not so
simple and yet as Steve said there are
these practices that can help you
navigate the path yeah it's very helpful
it's very instructive it's easy to read
and and it's laced with all of these
real-life examples to illustrate the
points that you're making and I found it
to be very impactful you guys did a
great job with this book so I'm super
excited that it's finally going to get
out there you have you also have amazing
blurbs from really cool people like
didn't Daniel pink give you a blurb and
because embodies this yeah
man the perseverance and the passion
over the long haul yeah you know what I
mean
awesome so are you guys gonna be doing
any live events coming up if people want
to come out and see you speak or you
know get a book signed or anything like
that yeah we've had a whole bunch of
stuff in Northern California so the
Thursday of launch week which is
Thursday the 21st we're doing a big
event at cafe called the firebrand where
we'll be talking about the book and
signing books and then Friday and
Saturday will be at the Oakland Marathon
awesome cool man well congrats and come
back when you write another book in
another nine months yeah I mean oh and
you know we're working on a TED if
you're listening Ted's our agent where
he thinks like a book should happen
every five years nonsense like we're
gonna die so he's moved us from every
nine months to every two to three years
three years yeah so what depends on what
kind of book yeah no but there's a lot
of research that goes into these books
too so I'd imagine I was pretty time
consuming yeah you know we go all in for
a little bit right where we come back
out so we get it done all right well the
passion paradox a guide to going all-in
finding success in discovering the
benefits of an unbalanced life that's my
favorite part the benefits of an
unbalanced life because I agree with
that wholeheartedly and guys did a good
job
thank you so much everybody go out and
check out the book it's an easy read
it's short - how many pages is it just
like yeah it's like 160 something like
that so all right now I'm will much love
to you guys and best of luck with
everything coming out if people want to
connect with you online at be Stolberg
and Steve you are Steve Magnus
correct keep it simple it ER and
Instagram and all the like yep all right
man
peace thank you rich plants
[Music]